[Musique]
à quoi bon tous ces
bienens à quoi bon cette richesse cette
[Musique]
opulence si
cétait le progrès des sciences et des
techniques depuis le 19e siècle
l'industrialisation ont amené une
croissance économique qui ces 25
dernières années dans le monde a été
supérieure à ce qu'on a faitit fait
depuis un
siècle et tout ceci a conduit à ce qu'on
appelle péjorativement ou non la société
de consommation c'est-à-dire une
abondance de bien et paradoxalement au
moment où la situation est ainsi on voit
les
germes d'une inquiétude qui est déjà
celle de la société
post-industrielle car à quoi bon tous
ces
bien à quoi bon cette richesse cette
opulence si les hommes n'arrivent pas à
résoudre les problèmes fond
qui sont les leurs c'est-à-dire leur
épanouissement personnel leur relation
avec l'autre la maîtrise de leur destin
personnel et collectif et alors dans ce
monde fondé sur la rationalité nousous
éloignons de plus en plus de nos
impulsions profonde l'impulsion profonde
c'est la terre le soleil l'air l'eau les
rapports humains la nuit la sexualité la
nuit le silence et nous avons besoin de
retrouver
et le monde de la rationalité nous donne
des sécurités des certitudes et des
biens si ce monde de la rationalité ne
se dépasse pas pour nous redonner tout
ça alors ça fera
Bou